je
la planète bienvenue à la caméra vérité
de tam-tam canada elle est là la caméra
ça lui la main millions de personnes
présentement presque un million enfin
c'est notre espoir éventuellement va y
arriver
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous cette
semaine pour une autre édition de
tam-tam canada qui vous parvient en
direct de moyens quelle heure est il
presque
11h11 on a devancé les choses de quoi de
quelques secondes on prend de l'avancé
parce qu'on a une grosse émission
beaucoup de choses à discuter ensemble
autour de la table regardons qui sont là
les favoris enfin ce que vous connaissez
depuis longtemps vous les voyez tous les
jours
gimeno bonjour bonjour bonjour marie
claude simard bonjour jours ces deux là
sont des webmestres dont des
spécialistes des communications sur le
web et les spéciales de la communication
sur la radio nous nous c'est la vieille
les vieilles techniques technologiques
arrivant aujourd'hui marie bonjour
stéphane et puis elles viennent voir
même si elle appartient à un autre
service complètement oui elle a déjà
travaillé activement à ercis aujourd'hui
le remède pour le service autochtone
espace espace autochtone est avec nous
cette semaine puisqu'il est là souvent
au sein du service français de radio
canada international
notre collègue et amie alice chantal des
mots bonjour ali stéphane toute l'équipe
jouera liste un jour alors on va avoir
un ennemi un invité mystère dans
quelques instants
on dit pas qui c'est parce que vous vous
le connaissez ou juste d'ailleurs en
quoi son prénom vous le saviez mais pour
vous le présenter
il ya un petit préambule qui nous mène
tout directement au thème de l'émission
aujourd'hui
vous connaissez le jeu anne-marie ça
fait trois semaines vous n'êtes pas venu
dans cette ville il ya bulma ici c'est
nouveau c'est nouveau c'est la semaine
dernière à chaque semaine on ajoute un
élément ça coûte 5 $ additionnels à
chaque émission demandé ça va coûter une
fortune faire six missions voici très
simplement c'est à vous de parler moi je
réponds que par oui ou par non vous êtes
prêts vidéo numéro 1 quel est le thème
de cette émission tous les âges
regardez ces images est moins qu'il
attaquait le terme aujourd'hui poser des
questions mais là attendez là papillon
un papillon qu'elle mon dieu on est
rendue je sais pas moins dix élus
là on est rendu avec les pigeons et sa
poésie l'endroit cool il ya quelqu'un
qui sait quelqu'un qui a voyagé beaucoup
voyagé je pense que vous avez trouvé un
bon prix importent les voyages mais
marie claude vous connaissez la réponse
des sages donnent des réponses parce
qu'elle est dans le coup l'inflation
j'aurais tendance à parler du tourisme
tourisme voyages de relâche scolaire
donc vacances prévues et louis leur à
l'âge dans les pommes pour vous c'est
important que huit fois par la partie de
ce qu'on pourrait faire comme
destination voyage destination
touristique
voila voila référés dans le monde et
pour les canadiens ou si oui de
canadiennes ici qui était en italie
quelque part ce que j'ai besoin de
représenter à nouveau l'image qui ont
débuté au monarque celui qui pratique
selon les saisons
alors maintenant vous avez vous savez
tout voici la première question revient
en studio images images planes images à
les autres images pleins son moteur faut
pas confondre
alors voici c'est notre première
question de notre jeu remuez vous les
ménages en bresse et pia trois manches
dans sept ans ce jeu à chaque achat
question il ya un certain pourcentage
que vous est attribué je veux que vous
preniez notre cette semaine vous avez
tous un stylo mais j'ai pas de match je
n'ai pas de papiers je prête pas jamais
déjà faire à l'école est-ce que je peux
monter dans mon téléphone vous pouvez
faire ce que vous présidez prend des
notes à l'occasion alors ça vaut pour
20% de l'examen final
alors voici qu'elle voici la question
très simple un coup pour tarir
fanta mise à claira
je sais pourquoi
ouais c'est la semaine dernière 4 on
adore aussi pourquoi vous partage c'est
mon visage je dis rien mon visage il y
tout parfum parfait alors voici la
question sur la liste des 50 citoyenneté
au monde
oui qu'ils aiment le plus voyagé à
l'étranger qui aiment le plus voyages à
l'étranger où se situent les canadiens
sur cette liste des 50 citoyens
citoyenneté du monde la came le plus
voyagé aussi celui des canadiens 10e
rang d'accord 10e pour alice ne vous
connaissez pas la réponse
moi j'irai victimes toujours là les
choses 7e et 5e ou copier tous les
copains à l'école mais c'est sûr que
c'est parmi les 10 premiers c'est sûr
vous pouvez tous vous accorder 1 20% sur
votre papier sont votre téléphone
vacances eh bien oui vous avez tous les
ans parce que avec la au moyen d'un
voyage par par année pour chaque
canadien
on est dans la liste des dix
nationalités qui m'aide le voyage dans
le monde
même ça augmenter beaucoup comme dans le
monde l'homme et pour les canadiens
c'est a augmenté de 92% nos voyages à
l'étranger depuis 1998 il y a donc 20
ans augmentation 92%
c'est des statistiques d'une firme dont
je mentionnerai pas le nom sinon ça
allonge des émissions et qu'est ce qui
justifie je supporte démocratisation des
voyages démocratisation du pouvoir
d'achat des conneries sur man puis en
fait maintenant n'importe qui peut
prendre l'avion fut l'occasion de partir
c'est une explication possible il faut
arrêter la boule de cristal sur
d'électricité jeudi
bon alors on a en partie la raison nous
on n'est pas une émission d'affaires
publiques on cherche pas les raisons
c'était quand même un peu remarqué bien
on reste contemplatif on valide à
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup voyagé dans sa
vie ah oui oui vous la voici le voilà
vous le connaissez parce qu'il est
apparu quelques secondes avant la mise
en
qui est il karima votre ami karim vous
la vôtre aussi
on le connais pas personnellement mais
cela très bientôt même attendait là ils
me regardent avec sa petite caméra
je vais vous montrer vos amis regardez
karim vos amis écoutent et karim
peut-être qu'en dehors du québec qui
vous connaissent pas je sais que dans
plusieurs pays du monde et vous
connaissent alors qui êtes-vous
et on dira ensuite de pourquoi vous
venez à l'émission aujourd'hui qui suis
guéri molette au sénégal j'ai vécu
ailleurs dans des pays d'afrique en
europe un peu partout au québec et
j'habite la ville de québec maintenant
depuis de nombreuses années déjà et ben
citoyenne du monde
oui est ce que vous êtes originaire du
cameroun oui oui je viens du cameroun de
yaoundé billets pas du même pays que
vous mais non il vient d'afrique
les gars c'est l'autre afrique c'est
l'afrique de l'ouest à sanya 57 pays je
pense en afrique au dernier concours où
58 54 54
oui bon d'accord il ya du avec le soudan
du sud est bien le dernier ni la
dernière née de salies 30 familles
affluent
karim il est passé en tunisie il a fait
et donc voyager beaucoup parce que vos
parrains ils étaient des québécois il
faisant adopter exactement on part
travailler dans la diplomatie des
retraites aujourd'hui
mes deux parents travaillent et au
sénégal depuis des années déjà et m'ont
adopté - en 1984 petite soeur sara mais
en 1986 et nous on nous ont un peu
traîné dans leur aventure pendant mon
enfance entre le sénégal tunisie le
rwanda le burundi et le qui vous fait
quelque chose dans les cordes aussi vous
avez voyagé quand même beaucoup dans
votre vie est relativement oui
probablement autant que pas plus que
vous elle n'en parle pas beaucoup mais
un jour si j'allais au japon au cameroun
et qu'est ce que vous connaissez du
cameroun et que nous connaît et yaoundé
un peu mais je connais surtout les
crédits
cette plage
ouais mais je n'ai pas aller à la plage
sinon la revente des entrepreneuses
africains de la forêt la forêt de campo
man alors karim vous êtes à l'émission
parce que c'est un mois spécial en ce
moment et vous avez été choisis on vous
a appelé vous n'avez pas hésité une
seconde mois quand on m'appelle je
réponds pas vous vous avez répondu la
tude de quoi il est question
je suis donc le co porte parole du mois
de l'histoire des noirs et de mireval
ashlee et on se partage en fait cette
semelle honneur leur tous les 2
proposait ce milieu de lieux plusieurs
mois déjà
j'ai réfléchi deux secondes et demie
avant d'accepter puis j'ai dit oui tout
de suite
on va passer des images pendant qu'on
parle ensemble de vous en train de
chanter un de vos récents succès qui a
beaucoup beaucoup fonctionné sur le web
pour ceux qui sont intéressés à
poursuivre leur découverte de votre
de votre talent on est monté dans un
avion j'ai choisi avec un avion dans ses
thèmes de l'émission comprenez bien
carrément aujourd'hui alors écoutez
choses sérieuses au sujet du mois de
l'histoire des noirs
je pense que on pourrait répondre à
cette question qui est nouveau cette
année comparé aux autres années est-ce
quelque chose on paie ce qu'on peut dire
c'est l'année 1908 web un mois en fait
si on parle de ce que je sais sur tout
ce qui se passe à montréal pour la pour
ce qui est de la programmation des
activités des choses à faire est
généralement au niveau des années
précédentes
j'étais pas toujours présent donc je
connais poste les anciennes
programmation sur le bout des doigts
pour être très franc avec vous je peux
vous parler de ce qui se passe cette
année en terme de nouveautés peut-être
que tu me mettrai pas la main ou veut
peut-être que je me trompe et cependant
cette année yeux des activités qui ont
déjà eu lieu mais qu'il y avait une
importance qui pour moi est est vraiment
particulière et c'est tout ce qu'il ya
eu un apport social si on veut mon petit
peut aider les gens piller des les
autres une activité qui est venu à
montréal il très peu de temps c'était le
17 février organisée de cancer avec
héma-québec une collecte de sang une
collecte de fonds pour une maladie qui
s'appelle li ning fred qui touche
beaucoup de jeunes de jeunes africains
beaucoup de jeunes noirs
oui allez y on a toujours besoin de dons
de sang pour ce qu il ya eu une activité
à montréal mais les dons sont dans le
besoin l'année longue pour ce long
chemin je profite de la tribune
aujourd'hui pour l'appui aux gens de
donner du sens et que l'ennemi
falciforme et et sont des causes qui en
a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup besoin en
ce moment donc je vous encourage à
visiter le mois de l'histoire des noirs
points comme pour tous les détails à ce
corps ou sinon il y avait des choses un
peu plus ludiques comme une exposition
sur la vie de prins qui a lu à la place
des arts en ce moment il ya une tonne de
spectacles de pièces de théâtre
tous se tire à sa fin puisque le mois de
février de tirer à sa fin
mais en dix stands site web on voit
comment on peut pousser un petit peu
plus loin que le mot film de février
pour les faits tous âges avaient une
question karim vous avez dit que vous
avez parlé des activités qui se
déroulaient à montréal
le mois de l'histoire des noirs j'espère
que c'est pas juste à montréal c'est à
travers le québec non à québec est ce qu
il se passe des choses et québec qui se
passe des activités aussi c'est le je
les connais un peu moins parce que même
si j'habite à québec j'y suis pas très
souvent la discussion qu'on hisse à un
humain peut être très très souvent donc
en ce qui me concerne ce qui dans mon
rôle de porte parole c'est pour toutes
les activités qui entourent montréal et
des alentours avec moi vous avez un bon
un bon copain moi je non plus je le
connais pas et webster ça vous dit
quelque chose
ouais je l'appelle le gangster même toit
et vous avez tourné une vidéo avec lui
sur un sujet très sérieux que ça
pourrait même servir dans les écoles
sinon sujets d'histoire jusqu'à demain
c'est une chanson qui s'appelle québec
history x qui ont été écrites par
webstore justement ça se trouve sur son
avant dernier album alors ne tournait un
vidéoclip avec soin et puis sur cette
chanson là il raconte une partie
l'histoire qu'on retrouve pas dans les
livres et qu'on se fait pas tout à fait
enseigner l école à moins de tomber sur
un propre particulièrement à lui mais
qu'il est c'est vrai le plus loin que le
cursus mais on se fait pas vraiment
parler d'autres sa part de l'arrivée des
noirs au québec en même temps que les
colons de personnes clés dont bloc pour
des gens jamais entendu le nom donc une
chanson avec une partie si une partie de
l'histoire qui demeurent dans l'ombre
et c'est sous une tout ces sources
facebook je suis conseiller toutes les
lectrices 52 minutes
fantastique j'aurai une question tarif
on sait que le mois de l'histoire de
l'histoire des noirs a été lancée en
1926 ça fait plusieurs années de cela
alors dites moi quelle peut être sa
pertinence encore aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui devrait
continuer à exister selon vous
absolument j'ai découvert quelque chose
qui m'a particulièrement touché cette
année
et puis je travaille beaucoup avec avec
des jeunes dans les écoles des jeunes
d'écoles primaires et puis j'ai
rencontré des gens de la diaspora à
montréal des jeunes au sport africaine
mais aussi des gens il sut d'autres pays
d'autres cultures
et puis une speed
sept ans si je me trompe pas qui
m'expliquait que son premier mois
d'activités son premier mois de
l'histoire des noirs ou est-ce qu'ils
aient participé à des activités c'était
il ya deux ans et puis dans sa classe
qui étaient surtout des haïtiennes les
africains mais il recevait des artistes
des gens qui travaillent dans le théâtre
dans là dedans sont les musiques dans la
culture qui va essayer de respirer les
plus jeunes
une activité qui avait lieu chaque année
seulement en mois de l'histoire des
noirs
et puis quand les professeurs ont vu
l'église une toque les étoiles dans les
yeux de ces jeunes là ça n'est une
activité qui dure pas toute l'année mais
presque donc déjà des choses comme ça
sorte du cadre d'un seul mois le mois le
plus court de l'année on va se dire et
puis continuer un peu plus loin ça me
touche énormément
puis je vois cela même façon pour un
petit peu toutes les activités qui tous
les sujets qu'on aborde avec tout ça le
mois de l'histoire des noirs grâce à sa
médiatisation dans les médias
francophones et anglophones permet de
mettre la lumière sur ce sujet certaines
activités
mais je vois ça comme un tremplin pour
que sept jeux finalement toutes les news
par contre il ya des auteurs célèbres
comme morgan freeman qui pensent que ce
mois là n'est pas pertinent dans la
mesure où il permet d'entretenir le
racisme la séparation le développement
séparé des races
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire avec
tout le respect que j'ai pour mon jeune
fille m'aime je suis un très grand fan
je pense que je pense que lui lui moi on
n'a pas l'air angie je pense que les
jeunes de la diaspora que j'ai
rencontrés au québec qui n'ont peu la
vision de la vie que mangane rennes peut
avoir malgré tout les similitudes
similarités conte avec des états unis on
est con société très distinctes avec ses
propres enjeux le mois de l'histoire des
noirs au québec dans le carré dans mes
yeux vraiment toute son importance que
c'est son niveau de l'éducation que ce
soit au niveau du bien que sa porte je
l'appelle
travail héma-québec fait avec le mois de
l'histoire des noirs et aux niveaux au
niveau très ludique aussi toutes ces
activités familiales pour les amateurs
de musées qui était requis il invite
tout le monde ou pour moi ça devrait
continuer pour toujours karim c'était
fantastique de vous entendre parler du
coeur fantasme ou les mots viennent très
facilement dans ce temps là puis on le
sentait chez vous c'est m'avait beaucoup
appris par votre simple présence merci
infiniment situation d'abord vous
quittiez avant de vous quittiez parce
que ça coûte rien ce cadre donc on peut
en profiter cet occident comme les
intérêts dites moi votre prochain voyage
la tendance vers un pays de rêve ce
serait vers lequel vous voyagez beaucoup
l'île maurice bompard était à quelques
reprises il ne parle que de ça donc un
projet maurice sanson quelque part au
nord de madagascar c'est ça à peu près
me semble que oui
vérifiez son bouquin c'est comme la
ville de sherbrooke c'est quelque part
par là
merci car et merci beaucoup
puis on vendredi non c'est un
sympathique et goûter c'est pas fini
maintenant pour les choses sérieuses
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas pour la
deuxième marche de notre quizz vous les
ménages non moi je peux donc allé voir
que j'avais écrit la can et la voilà je
pense et ça j'ai pas de questions c'est
pas une question est est-ce juste pour
voir si vous avez vous êtes capable de
vos yeux c'est ça fonctionne bien
auto mettrie vous est pris avec moi on
va faire apparaître quelque chose à
l'écran vous étiez vous voyez si vous
vous envoyer chez un spécialiste
ici aussi la question où les canadiens
préfère-t-il aller à l'étranger en ce
moment la réponse en kart entier donnez
moi des pneus dans des pays que vous
voyez mexique mexique pour commencer
france-cuba allemagne chine république
dominicaine
c'était quoi après je m'attendais la
chine arrive avant la république
dominicaine
parce que beaucoup de chinois et les
pays visités par les canadiens donc je
moi je me suis allé sur une carte de
radio-canada donc j'ai cliqué un peu
partout pour voir à quoi ça ressemblait
qui viennent il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vont en france en espagne bien sûr ohio
muni et après ça je pense que j'ai
cherché l'islande pour voir s'ils me
voyez l'afrique regardez l'afrique
choses qui se passent le relais
il ya beaucoup de coopérants québécois
canadiens qui se trouvent mêlés - de
peut-être que l'architecturé c'est que
vous et vous les infrastructures - des
effets nouvel avion très cher c'est vrai
oui oui vous avez l'expérience d'un seul
argument rial paris exactement
alors voilà seules les destinations les
plus populaires auprès des canadiens
vers les états unis
fleury dans premier jeu les snowbirds
moi ça m'a surpris ni aux rigueurs
maintenant trop loin
[Musique]
une idée tout va bien ou du côté des
yeux 20 sur 20 pour tout le monde c'est
de rester assis dessus on est à 60 ans
toi non ça va des justes pour vincent
alors on est prêts pour notre question
tam-tam cette semaine celle qui a été
mise sur facebook et à laquelle on a
reçu une réponse plutôt fantastique
voici la question
on va demander à liste de nous lire 7
alors c'est vrai que je suis derrière
l'écran je crois pas du tout à temps
est-ce que je peux être savary je veux
tourner davantage ça va s'arrêter dans
quinze secondes vous pouviez tout
quitter du jour au lendemain et vivre je
suis pratiquement derrière l'écran je
vois rien on va vous la faire rejouer
dans une peau bien quitter du jour au
lendemain et aller vivre dans un autre
pays quel serait votre premier choix
c'est une bonne question et on a reçu la
réponse de madame goze schüpbach en
bretagne france et quel est d'après vous
quelle est sa réponse c'est ça comme
séance un peu plus chaleureux
voilà attendez voir je me suis
maintenant prêt moi pour la question
numéro deux à notre quiz remuez vous les
manèges et avant que je vous pose la
question je voulais vous signaler que le
patron est intervenu dans l'émission
c'est la première fois qu'il le fait
vous voulez dire qu'il vient juste de le
faire il paye nous fait payer on parle
de lui chaque semaine alors ils
s'impliquent écoute il pas trop le
patrouille ça va mais il a dit cette
semaine là c'est du sérieux il va m'en
vouloir parce que j'ai révélé je pas
révèle la chose j'utiliserai donc je
paraphrase et je peux pas dire
exactement ce qu'il a dit mais est il
aurait aimé que l'on ait du dso pour
accompagner notre jeu
là il m'a demandé d'appeler le
département des farces et attrapes
ils ont fermé alors voici un animal ça
fait longtemps qu'ils ont fermé se
présentant au moins non mais j'aurais pu
appeler parce qu'il ya véritablement un
département pour les pour les
accessoires c'est comme ça qu'ils
appellent ça oui mais j'étais un étage
est différent et bon choix
alors moi j'ai pensé deux semaines j'ai
passé moi je moi je passais nouvelles
technologies vous prenez voile et les
gros boutons là qui font bomb ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup
j'ai apporté ma technologie ici au
travail et voici je vais vous demander
ce que vous en pensez
alors qu'on joue faux jeu c'est ça le
problème
[Musique]
la première c'était mieux d'accord non
pas celle non pas celle là attendez il
ya la douleur
[Musique]
c'est le projet avec ça c'est que ça
sommes pas très fort j'étais couché à la
maison n'avait rien mais lt je vais pas
fini on avait un dernier je pense qu'ici
coupât tahrir vous en avez trouvé
d'entre vous vous avez des bruits comme
ça sur le web
non c'est fantastique ça fonctionne donc
vous pouvez m'accompagner j'ai pas
besoin d'être un homme orchestre
voici la question numéro deux est prêt
en 2010 est qu'elle était la meilleure
destination touristique au monde en 2010
est donc à peine deux mois vous devriez
vous en souvenir qu'elle était la
meilleure destination touristique
augmente on commence par vous leonardo
et koumba koumba parce que ce soit un
pays pas une ville basse à pour être une
ville pays comme monaco mais c'est ne
figure pas dans les seules destinations
touristiques alors à l'iss
ça fait 3 secondes pour répondre
marie france dans les fromages new york
new york
allez-y la liste parce que je ne sais
pas celui qui se trouve le plus proche
de la bonne réponse va remporter 30 %
peut-être paris peut-être paris mais c
est ce que c'est paris parce que c'est
peut-être elle est gérée gérer avec
paris donc c'est certain série
l'attraction macro si on n'était pas
loin de paris pour tous les deux vous
allez remporter
vous avez dit new york les états unis
donc et vous le combat combat là va
falloir décider qu'est ce qui est plus
proche du canada kouba où new york et
new york
vous ajoutez 100 ça va on va mettre la
vidéo numéro 6 pour vous montrer la
preuve de notre science
voici alors pour moi qui ai décidé c'est
deux organismes très connu il ya le new
york times dans dernier qui a dit que le
canada en 2007 serait la destination
préférée mais est-ce que ça a été le cas
et non en 2018 non m et suggéré à ouidah
pas d'accord je vais s'il ya des points
que je n'ai pas accordé josé da cadrer
dans quelques secondes mais c'est un bon
choix et puis là il ya lonely planet
aussi qui avait désigné le canada comme
destination numéro qu'est ce qui
aiderait cependant c'est qu'en 2017 on a
connu ici au canada un record de
tourisme qu'on n'avait pas égalé depuis
2002 je pense je pense que le 150e
anniversaire du pays a dû faire un peu
c'est ça on met beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de moyens pour attirer les gens
pour des anniversaires particulier alors
moi je veux revenir pour trois centièmes
du canada
allant vivre éternellement pour cela il
va au marchand de glace conservent bien
vous voulez vous aller en egypte c'est
moins cher
vraiment alors sans le temps risque
sérieusement cette année encore une fois
le canada ait des signes et kuzi
s'arrête pas avant 2018 pour demain 18
mais pas tout le canada seulement une
région du canada l'ouest l'ouest et
renault vancouver ben non mais ça a
remarqué ce sont les zones touristiques
les plus importantes du canada ça aussi
non non pas l'ontario et la ville de
québec et la ville de ses pâtes riz
moins dé l'unesco il y at il beaucoup
déjà je connais des gens qui sont venus
vraiment visiter sa lé québec pour ces
analystes
on vient de dire non les prairies
canadiennes c'est un endroit que
beaucoup de canadiens
je vous laisse de côté d'or j'irai un
jour mais c'est un peu loin s'est un peu
éloignée ces normes tout à fait
complètement dans le nord
[Musique]
oui à démonter superbes montagnes pelées
vous ben c'est pas les rocheuses
parce qu'on va montrer les images
peut-être que ça va vous donner une idée
vous allez regarder la géographe et
cadets signer cette zone comme la zone
touristique numéro un pour le canada
cette année c'est au quiz
pas grande image là c'est une carte
ce sont des montagnes qui sont qui sont
les glacis sont passés dessus et donc
s'arracher tous les arbres restent plus
tout à fait et par il n'y a pas beaucoup
de gens moi je suis déjà passé tout ça
si vous faites de voyage paris montréal
un jour vous arrivez à la côte
canadienne vous regardez en bas c'est ça
c'est vu de haut c'est moins pire que la
corse attendait que ce pas qu'il ya un
an près six essais de l'amérindien le
tri moi je suis pas spécialiste je vous
demandais je papote panne colle mal
parce que doit faire une faute c'est moi
c'est le parc à camille ou atchik 4k
soit clément mairie c'est long comme don
mais c'est beau et on recommence avec un
guide autochtone
c'est ce qu'on dit 7,9 la réserve du
parc national à came in cheek kaka sous
ac c'est joli merci de l'avoir bien ça
donne envie d'y aller encore donc vous
pourrez ajouter ça à vos endroits à
visiter cette année anne marie bouché tu
sais que vous aimez voyager oui
peut-être pourriez leur faire découvrir
à tous belle région c'est pas dans cette
direction que je pense mais on se donne
jamais trop tard on peut en parler votre
patron si vous voulez y a pas de
problème non mais vous savez ce que je
vais faire cet été
non traverser le canada en train de
partir de montréal jusqu'à vancouver
bravo aux navires oui en train puis
marines et les trains c'est très spécial
ses débuts bacon avec des endroits
avec un sky ils appellent ça le sky love
oui non mais en tout cas oui et
s'arrêter en chemin dans les prairies ça
coûte une fortune
oui mais je travaille fort strife plus
que 3000 $ c'est la seule la dernière
fois que j'avais compris une cabine
privée des toilettes j'ai pas besoin de
grand chose que je peux dormir sur mon
siège
et c'est ça mais c'est vous allez faire
ça au oui non sans blague
mais en fait je veux le faire dans
l'immédiat cet été non messieurs je vous
le souhaite à les combiner travail et
plaisir et puis non non non non c'est
par le tout cas j'espère parce que c'est
assez difficile d'avoir des vraiment un
sentiment d'être en vacances le pouvoir
oui mais par contre j'ai déjà traversé
les rocheuses en train et c'est assez
extraordinaire on voit les ours l'aller
les oursons la ce sur ce point parce
qu'évidemment les traits n'en prennent
pas les même chemin que les routes
ok on est vraiment en pleine nature et
ses fabuleux c'est fabuleux
je me demande si on ne pourrait pas
continuer à voyager mais à kouba ok
c'est là que vous pensez que les cons
devrait à nouveau puis d'ailleurs les
québécois moi je vais avec le gars des
vues comme un tissu avec le directeur
les matches où tu fais il paraît que
c'est là que les québécois vont le plus
souvent en voyage mais je pensais que tu
es le mexique notre il semble que ce
soit le cuba pour ce qui est des
canadiens anglais de destination
préférée le mexique et s'était un peu
moins maintenant y'a un oui des
républiques
moi je rêve d'aller là mais je veux pas
traverser la frontière américaine donc
et pourtant vous le faites presque ça va
sans problème aucun problème
toutes les semaines nous ont toutes les
années je me je fais un effort
particulier pour pour le rock le rock
raconter ma vie est alors passé mon
passeport pour qu'il vérifie les
antécédents
non c'est toujours sympa ça on en a
parlé on a fait une émission spéciale
souvenirs voyage bon écoute et voici on
voyage à cuba mais quand on en vit à
cuba qu'est ce qu'on apporte dans ses
valises pour offrir aux gens qui sont
sur place
plein de petites choses weeds est en
fait du dentifrice des brosses à dent de
lion en couleurs des articles de base en
fait pour pour les soins ou s'ils
souhaitaient qu'on est les seuls à faire
ça je sais pas ces américains font ça
mais nous on est sensible au fait qu' il
ya des pénuries cuba année c'est son nom
est à ce point
oui ces communistes jeu sétifien pénis y
est ça j'ai quand même ça coûte cher et
plus ils et j'apprécie beaucoup les
gestes comme un cadeau soi même plutôt
que de l'acheter c'est un peu sa route
en offre quelque chose si tu vas avec de
l'argent canadien ça vaut pas grand
chose s'ils vont changer l'argent c'est
pas les méchants que nous on pourrait
avoir à leur apporter des choses des
bâtiments c'est bien un organisme qui
était kenny ya quelques années qui
s'appelle not just touristes donc en
français c'est plus facile à dire pour
juste des touristes la jce des touristes
mais ils ont enlevé le drap ce soit plus
qu ça passe plus facilement sur le web
pas juste touristes en france est
tellement mais c'est bon ça ça passe
alors c'est comme la dictée moi quand
j'ai tourné en france pas français mais
ça passe moment alors écoutez je vais
pas changer beaucoup depuis ce temps-là
jeu
voici on a cette entrevue avec une
responsable ici à montréal
ils vont pas seulement à cuba mais il
apporte des valises quand ils partent en
voyage une passe manquée bas mais les
petites républiques
les gens sont dans le besoin partout où
ils vont ils ont cette obligation et se
donne cette obligation de faire la
collecte de médicaments qui seraient
périmés dans quelques temps par exemple
auprès d'hôpitaux et d'amener son nom
leurs valises et c'est tout à fait légal
bien sûr des fois il faut demander des
permissions il faut faire des
vérifications parce que la douane
peuvent se reposer pour déposer les moi
même mais à des documents qu'on peut
signer alors voici cette entrevue qui a
été réalisé par raymond des marteaux
avec cet invité on va tous découvrir
avec cette image et cette vidéo le
médicament et de ses médicaments ma
famille donc une personne peut aller sur
le site et dire moi je serai prêt a
transporté une valise de médicaments je
m'en vais en équateur je m'en vais au
panama je m'en vais à cuba par exemple
et on arrive à s'inscrire comme ça
[Musique]
fournit une lettre qui nous loue à terre
mais est ce que c'est une valise
d'extras que le voyageur doit retirer
une de ses valises autorisés ou ip un ex
un nom qui donne la balle à l'hôpital
d'accord à ce moment je trouve des
petits sacs haut dans leurs mains c'est
un des leurs c'est vraiment simple c'est
fait ils promettent le spectacle dans sa
propre vin disent oui c'est ça le mague
été le premier pays qui vivent tous les
thalys mais la valise tout seul fait de
simplement à chaque auteur de romans et
ses thèmes taille le passage est capable
de donner donc si pas juste c'est pas ça
juste rice est plus que touriste je
voyais des livres à des agents
humanitaires parce qu'ils tracent les
médicaments qu'ils déposent dans des
hôpitaux
j'allais poser la question justement en
ce qui concerne la gestion de ces
médicaments l'a par la suite
heureusement la dame a donné la réponse
les produits qui sont déposées dans les
hôpitaux parce qu'ils pensent après
présenter un certain danger d aller
comme ça avec des médicaments qu'on
distribue à des gens voilà donc je
trouve que c'est une bonne action mais
pour ceux qui veulent obtenir de
l'information savoir où il se trouve
on a sur la page de tam-tam justement ce
reportage intégral l'entrevue les
détails les images c'est fait marrer
monde et bart aussi sur la page cette
semaine de tam-tam canada j'ai ainsi
quelqu'un qui participe avec nous c'est
jean rémy cazals qui dit paris c'est la
meilleure destination touristique au
monde
puis après 10 canada mutuellement puis
10 au message à vous puis en fait cette
femme qui est anne marie et dit stéphane
jamais oublier la charmante voix et toi
tu c est celle d un mari vont chaque
fois que stephen âmes appelé allocation
je collais mondiale pas par des
émissions on est en relation avec le
monde vient de téléphone c'était dans
les années cinquante et une finale parce
que c'est quand même plus récent que ça
mais jean remy à cette époque je pense
que vous appeliez à hawaï où vous avez
du marié tout une dame
quoi qu'est ce qu'il y a qu'est ce qui
se passe à vous avez coupé le signal non
non on attend pour la prochaine vidéo à
vous attendez encore quelque chose il ya
autre chose qui s'en vient voici
d'ajouter nous en avait des meilleurs je
pense pour aller vous outiller traîner
fantastique voici dernière question on
t'a mis des lumières honteux par le
programme famille des lumières voilà
c'est prêt pour la toise et les
dernières questions qui vous maintenant
pour combien de % d'examen 60 non ah bon
ce n'est pas vain
non 20 30 ans ben alors on est rendu à
50 on est rendu là 50
vous me donnez vos scores c'est au tour
de table je suis autour de 40%
vous croyez mais vous avez pas parce
qu'il y avait une question de vin une
question tandt devait remporter les deux
vous avez 70 non non non non donc cette
vraiment enregistrement où je suis la
seule qui a gagné la deuxième question
donc vous avez 40 pour cent
quatre-vingt-cinq comment elle connaît
les princes alors alors voici c'est très
simple et dernière question va le zéro
alors non pas 40 % on va dire qui et
combien vous aviez sérieusement la 20
ans fonctionne super bien sûr et il nous
a donné ça vient tout seul au départ oui
oui oui
20 vous étiez pas se poser d'écrire ça
sur la burqa mais jamais deux des vingt
alors je mets karam je sais pas pourquoi
c'est 80 quelque chose je vais vous dire
quelque chose la semaine prochaine je
vous donnais 20 $ 20 $ 30 $ 5 ans d'art
vous allez vous en souvenir de vos
stores alors on mettrait pour la
question si vous remportez vous êtes
automatiquement là où la gagnante parce
que 50% ça pèse lourd
voici mais si ça fonctionne pas une gêne
notre jeu notre une autre âme
voici troisième question voilà si vous
mettez au défi le toqué voici les
touristes canadiens et québécois à cuba
doivent composer de plus en plus avec
quoi lorsqu'il s'y trouvent dans ce pays
les canadiens l'étoile canadien
québécois à cuba doivent composer de
plus en plus avec un problème c'est vrai
choix de réponses
j'en appelle à ceux l'hépatite b celui
qui se trouve le plus proche de la
vérité et à l'hépatite b
ouais d'accord je passe mon tour mais je
vais je vais revenir
vous avez j'ai besoin de réfléchir ali
al marri des moustiques des moustiques
oui peut-être l'hépatite
j'atteins je dirais pour les pâtes
j'aimerais que les moustiques ses
proches de la sécurité routière la
sécurité routière dans ce sens tout en
étant va nous très bien alors c'est
pratiquement des moustiques qui sont au
contact des touristes américains
voilà ça pique de plus en plus parce
qu'évidemment je sais pas il ya des
enquêtes y en a beaucoup en tout cas
trois cent mille l'an dernier durant les
six premiers mois des cinq premiers mois
de l'année 2017
c'est dénombre incroyable pas autant que
les canadiens millions et plus si je me
souviens bien plus d'un million mais
c'est quand même une sérieuse
compétition et ça doit faire augmenter
le prix de n'importe quoi notre paradis
loin du canada et comme avec tout cru
mais en tout cas c'est quand même bonne
nouvelle parce que si ça peut aider le
tourisme dans l'économie du pays
c'est tant mieux donkey et c'était vous
avez oui
donc j'ai pas besoin de sortir mon arme
absolue c'est un mari qu importe ce qu
une dernière question oui à l'isi c'est
quitte ou double
donc si vous l'avez pas m'arriver sont
remporté tous bien sûr alors récemment
l' agence des fonds frontalière
canadienne du canada a donc lancé une
campagne auprès des touristes américains
pour qu'ils cessent d'apporter quoi avec
eux lorsqu'il rendait il venait faire du
tourisme au canada et seulement services
frontaliers canadiens ont dit on va
lancer une campagne pour informer des
américains pour qu'ils cessent
d'apporter quoi avec eux lorsqu'ils
viennent en touriste au canada une arme
donc hier soir c'est pas drôle notre
champion de détrôner n'est pas grave
elle n'avait pas besoin de répondre
d'accord vous alliez dire la même chose
c'est bien
je voulais même pas le dire je veux même
pas entendre ce mot là je vous donnerai
pas les statistiques non plus parce que
elle c'est en augmentation désolant à en
placer messier messier 30 kg asic et la
façon des contrées faim qui sévit dans
les écoles avec partir fier et qui
tirent sur des enfants à tout va donc
franchement c'est quelque chose quand le
problème pour contrer les armes c'est
d'ajouter des armes
enfin ça me semble être un non sens vous
dire moi je suis pas de politique là
mais simplement d'un point de vue de
logique que je pense que vient de
quelque part il y avait un policier qui
était sur les lieux afin qu'ils étaient
pas en uniforme qui n'est pas allée
intervenir
curieusement je dis restez à la pourtant
ils étaient armés et oui pourtant il est
armé
puis pour parler mal pour faire sentir
mal mais si trempe n 2 0 c'est une
petite jeune de 14 ans venez chilienne
une des héroïnes oui parce qu'il avait
retenu curieusement il ya un an et
arrêter ni une des parts
ils les gars y'a pas pu rentrer dans le
jeu
nous allons y était lui un prof vie
retenu la porte les professeurs lui
l'accord que je savais pas on en
découvre tous les jours vous avez
récemment avoué c'était sur les réseaux
sociaux
ouais bien venez écouter merci beaucoup
alice d'être venu cette semaine la
partie c'est merci pour l'invitation
c'est un peu comme ils ont été cueillis
les athlètes arrivent mais ils repartent
avant la fin des jeux ça arrive très
souvent j'ai déjà très occupé c'était un
plaisir d'être avec vous aujourd'hui
c'est en famille ici
merci tu n'es pas quoi allemands
arrivent on peut pas quitter la famille
maintenant je reviens je vais toujours
voilà
marie-claude on leur souhaite ne jamais
vous perdre c'est toujours un plaisir
non non c'est bon on le souhaite tous et
puis aller où vous êtes vous êtes comme
un frère alors on s'en inquiète pas pour
vous très bien merci mais j'ose pas
quelle caméra on dit bonjour